okay four people joining the livestream
we are going to be talking about a
knotty problem which is the
representation of truly symbolic
variables and generated parameters so
this is actually a notebook oh boy I
opened it in the prototype build let me
actually not do that that seems like a
bad idea this is a notebook from 2015
about previous discussion we had about
this let me actually move around my
let's see you said there's this thing
called variables right so I'm gonna move
my things called formal variables into
that directory called variables that
make sense
[Music]
why I hate the way that this when you
copy paste um okay what so here we go
this is our 2015 notes on form variables
we seem to have a second one from that
what is all this yeah this is less
importance like some experiments the
variables that books could be
interesting as well okay and what did we
end up doing with this this is for
system model what did we end up doing
with this in the end Roger Roger here
yeah Roger I think you're a mute zoom
says his mic is off I think that the
idea was finally using quantity variable
for various okay cases can you hear me
now
yes we can okay so what do we finally
end up doing with the system model of
variables I can't remember right now can
we look it up I mean they can look it up
but not right away do something to have
some other discussion in the meantime
okay all right okay let's talk about oh
look at this we've got axiom system data
Wow already from 2015 we were talking
about that um okay
okay so maybe Jonathan can say something
about axiom system data and what's going
on with that right now some things yeah
I can do I mean I can show I can show
the prototype of axiomatic theory okay
that was its name right yeah okay sure
do you want to show it if you want to
mail me something and I'll show it it's
probably easier if I show it cuz it's
not it's not in the external yet okay go
for it okay so the idea is you give some
name of an axiom system you know like no
it's to Huntington logic or something
system modeler uses formal variables yes
so we do the same thing so we we have
all of our quantified symbols are four
symbols and then the idea with axiomatic
theory is that you would then be able to
kind of the the operators you can
override so you can say something like
instead of all we're going to use F
whatever but the the moments at least
we're not providing any ability for you
to kind of override what variable what
formal symbols get quantified over in
the axiomatic system that gets returned
all right but to be real in this case
you know you say there's a formal
variable but there's also a formal
operator I mean the or is just for
entertainment value so to speak it could
be an arbitrary thing that yes so it's
purely that when it's a multi lesser
thing we don't worry too much about it
colliding with something else but that's
really not a and don't we have the same
issue yeah I mean the the Roger you
understand what's going on here yes yes
now I
talked about hadn't we that the language
so we've got constants we've got
variables we've got functions those are
the standard elements of mathematical
theory correct right and in principle an
axiomatic theory we could say yeah I
mean we could say in that Association we
could say you know constants arrow blah
I mean okay type this out just tell it's
a mathematical theory and then the
Association say you know constants arrow
and then a list for example or generate
a function well I wouldn't say e goes to
I mean hmm something like that yeah but
then we need to discover a interface for
the axiomatic theory to know what the
elements are supposed to be all right
yeah well probably there will be a
default and then you see what the
defaults are and you can change them you
suggested using the kind of following
the finite group data scheme of having
you could call say axiomatic theory
operators and get back a list of
operators or you know x-men 3 constants
well the idea was to have axiomatic
theory being more like a data function
which is based on a common property
right which means we might want to call
life semantic theory data right um okay
but so in this case you know one of the
big issues is what's the default right
because the default that you have there
is is stomping on earthing that's called
or not
well not at the moment because we're
using strings but that's even I know you
have some objections to that yes okay
it's okay so so this is very similar to
a you know differential equation where
you generate or a constant of
integration where you're generating C of
1 it's a function where you're
generating something and the most
important thing is it not collide with
an thing that exists and the second most
important thing is there's not be too
obscure and it doesn't have a value that
can really confuse you know let's say
it's designed to be value 3 yeah that'll
be disastrous
alright so the requirements okay let's
get let's go back to my screen yep well
what are we trying to what's the
question here it's a generator
parameters or is it it's yes it's all of
the above because there are a lot of
different things that are look a
coordinate chart data it's generating
you know formal variables here right
right right I don't know what this is
doing what's this doing that's
generating some kind of some more
precisely coordinates R theta is using
fewer variables and the you know slot
variables and PDFs use formal variables
which can't be assigned to and so are
essentially localized yes this is using
both using slots and it's using
difference between the variables and the
parameters so a is a parameter of
bipolar because those parameters come
from the data that you didn't give it
yourself as a user ability distribution
if you use the parameter and there you
put it in here I'm saying you I think so
but go ahead what no I'm just saying
that there can be parameters there too
but the variables are not done as those
bruni unique symbols
yes you know but but they're done with
formal variables but there is a there is
a path that's done to replace whatever
you give with formal variables so it can
survive mm-hmm so if you accidentally
assign something to that X you won't
ruin your probability distribution okay
so hold on let's let's go back here you
know we've got a bunch of things here
that are generating formal variables
okay this is a case where it's
generating them inside a function which
it doesn't actually need to do those
could be hash one and hash twos but
that's thought to be too obscure oh no
couldn't they be I mean what's that
that's a primed version of that right
just got really obscure yeah
typing put themselves on mute um we
tried with hashes for a while it was
just completely unreadable all right so
look one possibility and then again we
got a bunch of background noise here
which would be really good to fix okay
so one possibility is its formal
variables and we just say I mean the
case we've now it's biggest problem with
formal variables or all the dots I know
they're just ugly yeah I mean let's see
if we can't figure out a better format
ignore them maybe that's our only
problem
not really the fact that they are
limited in numbers one okay
well I mean the trouble with this is
it's either a symbol or it's not a
symbol you know if it's not a symbol you
could potentially go inside it I mean
that was why we were discussing before
like four or five years ago actually we
discussed it um you know we discussed it
when Version three when we were looking
at version three we almost introduced
kind of symbolized mechanism in version
3 and I think Jason Harris has long had
this
a cage that does some kind of symbolize
mechanism yes why can't we have some
sort of parameterised infinite family of
fools at once rather than some finite
set because what's a symbol see it's
either a symbol in which case you know
it's a named thing with a where the name
is a string basically or and then all
symbols the only feature of a symbol is
its string name that's the only thing
that is special about a symbol well
unless we start messing around with
attributes for example I mean in you
know in principle I mean if I say
attributes of I don't know what N or
something okay fine I'm not very
exciting but but like II or I yeah okay
okay so constant is an interesting
attribute because that attribute I mean
okay so there are a couple of features
of this and by the way if I say
attributes of formal a it's protected
okay so it's a symbol which is by
default protected yeah yep I mean in
principle we could have some attribute
based thing that could be set for any
symbol that could represent and until
you can set protected for any symbol but
we couldn't principle set this to be you
know I mean the cases that we know we
have are you know operator variable
constant those can all in different
situations be formalized able so to
speak like for example in your
coordinate chart data
constant AAK a parameter there that a
fair characterization yeah so I pasted
it into the chat a well many times
variable play the same role as parameter
it's just of a matter of perspective
rather than constant I'm saying
parameters more close to variable in
many cases than constant okay
but different functions take different
perspective on this this is why we can't
have a global theory so to speak um okay
but fair enough but I mean so let's see
by the way could we try to get um Jeremy
to join this meeting yeah okay okay so
all right so the question here
what what is the issue the issue is okay
we need things which have can't be
assigned values we would prefer if they
were somehow unique
but I don't think we can achieve that
without making a big mess another thing
that comes up repeatedly and we end up
building it multiple times is that
sometimes we need to generate you know
parameters and a ways to get them unique
is to use unique but unique we'll come
up with you know insane looking things
they're not for human consumption you
know I'm saying it might be like numbers
you know k dollar 10,000 31 right you're
in the beginning of session so it's
fairly low but but so we often implement
a scheme to make sure that there are no
you know a separate scheme to make sure
that they're low numbers so to speak you
know one two three you know which is
unique to within that expression but not
globally unique you know I mean
obviously that's unique well but doesn't
that you don't want to see that in a
formula do you know you don't
but and the other problem is you ever be
able to pick something up and kind of
you know it would be nice if it was
typable what do you mean well it'd be
nice if the thing you saw I mean we
could clearly have a blob that has a
UUID inside it the problem of that it's
copy paste oral but it's not typable
right I mean in the case here with your
coordinate chart data
the thing is in principle type of all
yep
okay so Jeremy we are talking about dot
Enis okay are those dots gray I can
hardly see they are great and they're
generated by the front end Jonathan
could you just send me a giant dotty
formula sure Oh
[Music]
better in mail because it may be
multi-line we really should have some
chat sessions going here okay okay so
the first question is can we do any
better than the dots here and I think we
have to and I think there was an issue I
mean these are not font characters
anymore are they just sent there
somewhere in between right so they the a
is from the font and then the two dots
are generated by the front and fearsome
algorithm so you know and you would need
John to if you need the details of that
algorithm then we need John John Folse
yeah I mean in principle just like the
thing we were just doing with the
approximate numbers we could you know
box these things or something else we
don't need just dots I mean we don't
have to have just dots correct it's a
decoration of some kind
it's
yes it's an algorithmically generated
decoration so we can in fact change it
if we want to okay well I mean that
seems like a win right there to begin
with I mean if we could change that to
be a box or a different color
what is it is it trying to communicate
something specific or it's trying to
communicate that it is a formal variable
which can't be assigned a value and is
sort of truly symbolic so to speak okay
is there a set standard for this already
do people do this
no no I think it's a statement for a
hundred years there hasn't been standard
unless it's maybe using I don't know I
mean for some things it's using gothic
characters but I don't think we can
really go to that that was the early
part of the 1900s
that's the Hosea Jonathan want to
comment on that all Roger I there
various sort of micro standards if you
use a n K or M you assume that it's an
integer and if you use X Y Z you know
letters at the end of the alphabet you
assume it's no I understand that but the
question is what what is the case of a
look when you have a generated variable
I mean what we've been doing like like
the C sub 1 or we're still we're still
formatting that as a C in the prototype
build that C of 1 is going to be
rendered as some kind of other thing
let's take a look at it
right I was going to mention that the
standard for something like lambda
calculus would be to use de bruyne index
notation but that's a little bit
unwieldy for general use what does that
do a good question
it's not like well but there are two
things here one is how do you ensure
that the names are unique and and that's
the technique of the pro analysis but
then typically when you are going to
typeset them to replace them by ABCD so
you never see their Charlie Brown
indices right yeah but those ABCD are
just standard Roman ABCD right there's
no yeah I don't think there are general
techniques for this because in general
in a book there is no need to
distinguish one variables from other
variables
it's just our problem that we need to to
make sure that users do not give values
by error right now okay so what could we
do is typographical conventions we could
make them okay so I mean one possibility
is type of graphical conventions
distinguishing you know the topic is how
to distinguish formal variables so we
could make them you know so there's a
variable we could make it we can't make
it bold because it's already bold I
think that would unbold it I mean we we
you know could be bold italic double
struck
you
how do we I mean if I say
oh gosh is that better or worse than I
don't know that's interesting how would
we feel about this so because that's the
convention we're using for the C of one
right here it's day nine bold because
the bolts are mess
well most of the time it would be seen
in non gold so how would you feel about
having a double struck a there let's
let's try what's a good example let's
try this I mean my main worry is then
you know how can you tell the difference
between you know a normal double struck
a and a formal a well you're saying any
typographic convention we invent there
will be well I mean you can always say
that any type of graphic convention we
invent will have the possibility that
they can be blown up by well if the
convention is to simply reuse an
existing technique than yes right and we
have right we have double right you know
we always name it we could obviously
just name double struck we could we
could have a thing which is slightly
different in appearance but it's
basically using the double struct idea
right and which is simply a rendering of
doubles of the okay so let's try this oh
for goodness sake how do I do that
replacement that should have worked
unless differential route is no entry oh
[Music]
it's because it's sculpt by right it's
sculpt by the function oh yeah its head
it's in their head Stephen it's a
compound head it's a complicated
function right so it's it's the head
that looks a hell of a lot better don't
you think that's just dramatically
better
yeah as I said I think that those don'ts
are there one of them with everybody is
not happy with it at least yeah right I
mean okay so is there a way I mean we
could invent a function that is called
something like formal symbol okay and it
simply takes a string and it turns that
string I mean maybe this is too much of
an unbelievable hack but we had that
proposal that we would have a you know a
variant a symbol called formal symbol
that would do what that would be make it
protected so you couldn't assign to it
don't think that we had typographic
conventions necessarily well then I mean
because because what happens right now
if I just say symbol of hello I indeed
get a symbol there but what this could
do is to return a symbol that is
typographically different and which also
is protected and in what context well
you can specify the context but by
default it will be global
you mean the current context yes
so then what would happen in some of
these things is in here for example it
would return formal symbol of a which
happens to be I mean it's a little bit
hacky because what we end up with is
we'd end up having to have I mean that
the most bizarre thing will be adi
formalized function right because the
question is do you ever go back from
having a formal thing do you ever want
to go back to an ordinary string symbol
or no symbol let's just let's just write
this for a second okay so formal symbol
of a string okay so now what we want to
do is let's find out where I mean this
is going to be a absolute hacker hacker
Saurus yeah Oh actually I know how to do
this I know this is that in private
unicode space yep that's another problem
right there is there a public Unicode
double struct character section
mmm don't think so but I wouldn't need
to double-check that okay so that will
be another problem if there isn't
because you know then we've got a
serializable it's a problem okay there
we go
so okay so let's say now what I say is I
can't really help me with this with
letter number I want to say letter
number okay
okay I claim this will do this it's not
actually gonna produce to simmer I can
make a police a symbol here and I can do
I could even set the attributes if I
really wanted to but here if I say
formal symbol of hello I get that
could be worse so in Jonathan's case
let's take a look at what Jonathan's
formula would look like um if you want
me to send you this person what do you
want - you can send me your formula and
I can substitute it or you can which one
I already sent you this is ring theory
out of interest okay happy to meet it
okay so what you're saying is this
should go formal eh
how are we dealing with this if I do if
I serialize this what is it gonna do if
I copy this thing - um a piece of email
for example is it just gonna blow up
there are probably substitution rules
but they don't know if they're beautiful
it's magnificent look at that beautiful
it turns into formal a formal B alright
so that's great so that means the
private Unicode space thing is sort of
irrelevant and really what we're talking
about here okay so maybe we can simplify
this discussion and what we're really
talking about here is just the rendering
of a B C and the fact that it happens to
be rendered as double struct characters
we wouldn't be you know be rendered as
formal a whatever and the question is
what is the formatting of formal a in
the making sense
yeah did that make sense yes I want to
bring something else and when you have
the moment okay let's just see what this
looks like
um and what operators be treated in the
same way yes gene Indian thinks that's
what I'm thinking as just sequences of
formal what I currently formal symbols
yeah that it would be that they would be
named they would use formal symbol and
formal symbol would would make all of
its string elements I mean this is you
know look arguably this is the world's
most disgusting hack but it's a hack
that's been around since the early 1900s
this kind of issue and I don't think
we're going to you know there's nothing
I mean in a perfect world we'd be using
you you IDs and things but yeah that
looks a hell of a lot better let's see
what happens if we go all the way with
um what are we doing with it with the
who's the RF goes to a formal symbol
and we've also got in hinge and II
actually which is treated as an operator
okay that's not that disgusting that's
perfectly civilized in my view now we've
also got a double struck D I mean we've
got differential D which is being given
in this double struck form and it's a
little different than double struck D
but you also have reals if you type in
reals
that has a tooltip so right so so type
in the following Steven yeah let me just
I can get rid of those good escaped es
capital z escape and then backslash : 2
1 2 4 oh did I know he didn't take it
ok backslash : 2 1 2 4 so one on the
right is the unicode double struck Z
Capital Z which is using presumably some
system font and the one on the left is
our private unicode double struck z
which is using the Mathematica fund ok
so I guess one possibility is we could
well I know I suppose this has the
potential for code breakage but one
possibility is we could repurpose the
the unicode ones as formal variable
there's no reason to do that there's no
reason to worry about that there's no
reason to actually take the Unicode code
points that way it's clear that we've
got enough that the substitution
mechanism going out a private Unicode
space will work fine we don't have to
worry about that this is really a
question of simply how do we render the
thing that's called formal a and right
now we've been doing it in this what we
might call dotty way which I just don't
think it's working
ok well I was thinking if we wanted to
have this formal symbol that takes more
right if we're just talking about
rerender you know changing the rendering
of a formal a that's well no but but the
issue is formal symbol would be the
thing that we would routinely use to
generate you know any symbol in formal
characters so to speak will also be used
but that character wouldn't be sort of
type of alright and it is typable
it could pain in the neck but it's
capable well it's not typable in the
sense that if you don't call formal
symbol if you don't evaluate formal
symbol first it won't have the
properties you expect it to have right
so like in the context of this axiomatic
theory stuff if I want to override the
you know the info operator or something
like it like passing an association do I
have to call formal symbol in and then
arrow something
well arguably okay so let's look at that
so axiomatic theory data and whatever it
is something or other now you are asking
whether we could well I mean we
certainly could make that work in
addition to having
you know we could have both things work
because they are clearly mapped to each
other in this case I mean this is you
know this hack disgusts me in various
ways you know the issue is okay okay
what's the right way to do this wait if
that's a symbol should that be in
quotations well I'm saying it could be
the string as well wrap it in the second
case that look that doesn't look like it
should be in traditional but it could be
in quotation marks I'm saying that allow
I mean we could allow the symbol and the
string and the D formalized string what
is the right way to do this so the issue
is we've got to have something which is
uniquely typable I think we have two
different things here we could continue
with the variables being using using
formal variables but then the operators
for which we will need a lot more
variety could follow something like the
capital C of number but we could
generalize to something which is
something of a string and then it exits
like the string sorry I don't understand
yes so the variables so somehow we can
survive with 26 variables like the
formal variables I think for the
operators it will be nicer to have
something that meets many more letters
yeah that's what this is doing and I
don't think this is that horrendous to
write it out like that but we are going
to find problems with contexts and what
we were discussing of whether it goes
through some operators at first first
sets the protected attribute and since
is that why I mean I don't understand
why I'm not I'm not seeing why that's a
problem here I mean in other words the I
mean
that seems very weird is going back from
the formal symbol name to the non formal
symbol name in other words so I guess my
point is do we really need the operators
to be symbols can they be something
compound I well in this particular case
in general in different variables
clearly it's better if they are symbols
because with them maybe mirin and get
into functions but the functions
themselves we could do something like
instead of capital C of one could use
something of string well notice that C
of 1 you know we're subscripting those
things right in in the case of the C
object we're subscripting it yes
but imagine that we had some formal
function head that takes things and
format them like this drink you know
what's scary about that is it's you know
it reminds me of inactivated which is a
whole nother you know inactive some you
know N squared - and all right that's
somewhat similar to this yes but I
wasn't thinking is the think it it's
useful if we manipulate strings
basically because we avoid all the
problems with contexts of the symbols
for example if we have to generate these
objects during build time the build
system may complain about global the
current formal symbols are created in
system context right all right yes why
wouldn't we do that with formal symbol
well if it's going to be an arbitrary
number of
I mean I mean there are issues with that
right because the system symbols are
magic in various ways it's not the least
of which is how they're sent over math
link and so you know you will start
having issues with sub Colonels and
whatnot if you're automatically
generating new system symbols what's
special about them in terms of the sub
kernel no I believe they're a belief
that the known ones are actually not
sent as symbols but as codes and other
ones are still sent as symbols but
without the context okay okay all right
so I mean that optimization might get
very weird if you but okay so let's just
look at these other examples here okay
so in this case we are now committing
ourselves to using C of 1 do we actually
want that or we prefer to have used
formal C could whoever's typing or
making a noise in the background made
themselves I think for the cases that we
have with our sole diesel reduce C it's
a perfectly good default you can set it
to whatever you want but it's a
perfectly good default and the fact that
it comes out subscript that makes
everything look more okay what about the
K right that would have been nice to
have some kind of formal symbol for
boys are dipping we could but people
hate the dots they do everything they
can I know I know I know everybody is
running away from the dots right we got
it but I'm saying if it's double struck
instead of dotted I don't think we're
nearly is upset about it I mean let's
look at what this guy looks like if I
take that thing and I say K sub 1 goes
to you know double struck I try I could
just say goes to formal well might not
evaluate correctly let's just say double
struck okay maybe we could put the
subscript in there well here let's just
do that
that's rather beautiful there's no
problem with that at all do you agree
Roger yeah mm-hmm okay so sorry talking
about new typesetting for K of I or
we're talking about making the generated
symbol in the case of summation
variables be a formal symbol not okay
which is fine but we may need more than
one so then the question is do we index
them or do we use I think we index them
oh well we can use that's a good
question whether we have KLM and so on
and so on and so on I think probably we
index them
and we know if we need to index them in
other words if there's just one of them
we don't need to index it see the
advantage of having this thing is symbol
is that everything will just work
there'll be no kind of okay let's take a
look at some of these other ones here
yeah
we also separately have the issue of
whether we have a symbol blah blah blah
sub Max and so on yeah that would be
there's a lot of programming constructs
that are very you know they don't accept
any you know like module and block and
function and so on if you give it you
know a of one square bracket one or a
sub one they fail yeah we have I mean I
think that the way to deal with that
something like this formal symbol thing
that symbolizes X sub min for example
because I mean I can set a type of
string X sub min is a perfectly good
string right
and if I say symbol of that what's it
going to do
but there's no real reason why that
fails is there well that's discussion
we've been back to a few times but I
still 20 years I still don't see why
what the issue is I mean it's like yeah
the problem is that right that's linear
syntax now yeah but you don't I mean but
but really you know on the other hand so
linear syntax is very rich I could have
a whole integral be a symbol yes right
no but but we don't really need that we
need sort of subscripts and superscripts
and it's linear syntax is overly
complicated right because there is a
linear syntax form for this which is
perfectly civilized it's just that right
no work because you didn't insert the
linear syntax operators right so you'd
need back slash and then you know and
that will work and yes this was changed
for a reason and and this is correct
what reason the the the out the using
the full forming boxes and for full form
of strings
why because precise the fact that it
fixed a lot of buds it it's part of the
project to have sort of the string box I
don't think we should get distracted
with this right now
but but if I say for example string
length a percent forty one it could be
some large number 28 okay you can do to
expression of percent 41 yeah it will be
perfectly nice right because it'll now
be subscript of x comma Minton right so
I mean the question here is why are we
not allowing symbol to eat things like
that if it wants to
so one problem is you'd never know if
that was a symbol or a composite thing
but I think at this point we've gotten a
little bit more sophisticated about so
you know in this case okay so let's just
had this as composite symbols so the
thing that I tried to recall because
it's like almost twenty years ago that
we had this discussion and I think that
some of the things that came up was like
oh yeah do you want a pattern match on
yes to pattern match on the men okay
I'll tell you the new game in town here
is that we could twenty years ago when
we were talking about this for version
what was it for it was for host three
you know it was probably in three two
but it was definitely for four as well
came up I remember that it was a
discussion the discussion of this was
right before release and just for the
human channel here was a discussion
where we started the design discussion I
did a two and a half hour drive we were
continuing with design discussion
eventually I decided I was not necessary
for the design discussion I put the
thing on hold went out to dinner for two
hours came back the design discussion
was still going on and it didn't come to
a conclusion okay but the new game in
town is that we could render the x-men
differently we've never had that pasa
you know twenty years ago we didn't
seriously consider that possibility
see what I'm saying so we could render
the x-men so that it doesn't look like
you know because that just looks like X
sub men like x squared like anything
else so the question is is if we were
using this composite symbol you know is
there a way with color or rendering
somehow there's a Jeremy question that
we wouldn't be you you've lost about
right it's not typable it's not typable
without the symbol wrapper
I mean the only way to make it tight
bubble I mean okay the good news is that
okay there's a way to make it type of
all right there's a way to make it
typable which is to have the symbol
rapper be a command key but to do to
make a command key okay okay so the
answer is have a command key that does
symbol and evaluates in place okay
what is this analogous to which is
analogous to icon eyes right which has
that same behavior right so in other
words if I type something like you know
this and I go here and in this
particular case I'm getting the icon
eyes we don't have a command key for I
can eyes at this time control fine but
but if we had a similar thing here that
had a similar type of graphic convention
we will be able to do this you would
type except men you know the procedure
would be you type X sub men and then
you'd press this this button and it will
turn it into a symbol
and it would be type of graphically
different now arguably well okay so one
one weird thing to do no this is not a
good idea the question is this x-men
x-men should be able to be set you know
should be able to use be used assemble
like anything else with you know assign
values to it blah blah blah
I mean I think we will be able to do
once we have it as a symbol or we can't
get it as a symbol we should be able to
there's no reason to not have x-men
blank and things like this which we've
wanted for a long long time and making
sense yeah I think that would be
wonderful I think that the biggest
problem I mean one of the big problems
that we encounter is that a lot of
things in the core language if you like
you know like maybe table is fixed now
and we fixed all the calculus like
functions to not have that issue but
module and function and all of these
things you want them there too but they
don't work anything to do with a core
programming language right well I mean
okay so look there are two possibilities
either we changed the behavior but that
was the slippery slope that we went on
20 years ago well you know and then the
real question is you have x-men and it's
an expression not a symbol can you
pattern match on the men etc etc etc and
everything goes to hell from there on
out making sense so if it's not an
integrated thing if you think you're
going to you know monkey around with its
insides as opposed to merely use it as a
type of graphic handle then it's you
know they all gets confused okay so we
have normal subscripts where you can
pattern match right you can do X
underscore plink and pick out the
subscript at X's and then we have these
other guys which are sort of I know
what's a symbolized yes but but okay but
if there's a type of graphic convention
it's pretty obvious what you can you
know get into and what you can't I think
it's a pretty subtle distinction I mean
we everybody in this conversation
understands that I'm not sure what it
looks like I mean it depends on what the
thing it depends on what it looks like I
mean we haven't been able to do X sub
men I mean the other possibility is to
make another take another crack at
seeing whether we can flow it into
functions like module and pattern
matching I mean as I say the last time
we looked at this you know our
principles might have well I don't know
the you know our way of looking at it
might have changed since then the last
time we looked at it it was an
incredibly slippery slope that quickly
fell apart I think it's very important
to not let it go insane you know to
bound it somehow otherwise it's undoable
very quickly
I mean possibility yeah I mean so but
here's what we've been doing you know
for these these functions that are that
looked like iterators but they don't use
these poor programming language
constructs like Locke and so on because
those are not equipped to handle it but
they literally replace in a first-round
and then they can go into block and so
on and the implementation could do
similarly for God's sake
if it says problems sorry I'm sorry what
way we've been fixing these for some
table and yeah great and so on is to
debt there is a past it's done that
replaces all these so that if it's needs
to use block in these you know more
simple programming constructs that those
it replaces them with something that's
valid for those guys to use and then
goes back again afterwards yeah and
you're saying we could do that for the
programming language constructs - yeah
we should investigate that okay let's
investigate that that's one separate
thing the the the independent question
so your claim would be if we did that
maybe we could have a formal symbol
thing that is a wrapper rather than
being an actual symbol is that your idea
I think we're talking about two things
one is one is getting something that's
better than the dots for formal symbols
yes are protected that's one thing and I
think that's separate from having rich
or symbols richer looking symbols I
think it's
useful to know if we put them together
it might again be one of these two don't
go anywhere
well fair enough but I mean okay so okay
so let's let's get to some decisions
okay first of all let's try using double
struck instead of dots for just to
render formal a through Z okay
and we might want to change if we can
change the appearance of the double
strikes then so be it
maybe we can have some some gray double
stucking or something like that I'm not
sure but I don't think the double
chocolate so it looks bad I'm not sure
we have double stroke Greek characters
anyway so you know those will be new
right I mean this will have to be sort
of algorithmically generated well I
think we'd want these to be
algorithmically generated for others and
okay so jeremy has examples there's some
flavors of double struck we've got you
know we're seeing monospaced basically
the kind of courier variant but there's
also this aerial you know the sands and
the sarah version we could use plus
italics you know we could throw that in
there right and what about what about
Greek and so on I didn't so you have
formal Greek letters but I don't know
that we have Greek for that we have
double stroke Greek letters no I
understand so I mean we will need yes we
would need that great okay these are
this is a question of a font rendering
type thing and you know yeah I know it's
a pain to produce that but you know
relative to having dots all over the
place I think we can you know there's
better solutions there I mean there may
be some other typographic mechanism that
isn't double struck Ness although double
stroke may seems pretty reasonable to me
and I think it's sort of carry at least
I think it carries less baggage than
something like gothic like if I saw a
gothic letter I would think that's alley
algebra if I saw a clutter I would think
it was an old-fashioned German document
I mean Gothic is not the most readable
right in a similar way if I saw a double
Strunk letter I think it's a set hmm
right well so the question is is there
any other I mean right and we have the
script letters which I don't know if
that's useful for this also easier to
read
it's got this game yeah great
magnificent what the heck is that and
that means that we don't actually have
characters or glyphs for those points
and I realized that probably I'm
actually not sure why that is right so
this would be an archaeological endeavor
to tell you why but my head I would
guess that we had the other ones for
some reason elsewhere and so those exist
in the a code they were picking those
ones up from Unicode that there is a
script e in Unicode but it isn't in the
sequence here mm-hmm which is very weird
yep script E is 8 4 9 5 which is clearly
basic Unicode right so you know one of
the you know right we were sort of the
first to really go whole hog but because
you know we were sort of in development
with Unicode then you know we have some
of our own idiosyncrasies as a result
yes yeah 25 years Unicode uses okay well
we need to wrap this meeting up but I
think what we're concluding here is the
publisher should continue this but I
think we made very good progress
I think we've concluded two things first
of all we're going to use some type of
graphic convention for formal symbols
that is less arresting than dots we
probably will
a function called formal symbol that
creates the formalized version of any
string as a symbol protecting it and
using whatever type of graphic
convention we're using
um and we also are going to do an
investigation of whether we can finally
get x-men to work well if a formal
symbol is going to possibly probably
become a function should I provisionally
use that as the rapper in sort of
axiomatic theory data I think so okay I
mean unless unless somebody's I think we
can implement yo go ahead the formal
symbol yet right because in most of most
of the places where we want to use these
right it's it's the whole right
basically it's the whole it needs to
evaluate first in order to do something
useful right
and so correct but that's why I'm
suggesting that we have and in most
cases right it's going to or certainly
in a lot of cases it's going to be
inside of health constructs so you'll
need to sort of inject it well and if
you want in for something as a formal
symbol you're probably going to want to
type in and then press control-shift app
for something or whatever control come
on if I don't know what it'll be to make
it you know to formalize it so to speak
we're not going to get a completely free
lunch it's not going to be titanfall as
simply as you can type the standard
characters because it isn't the standard
characters right so I think that's the
least horrifying of the things we've
seen here now the only other possibility
is that
we can have a typographic convention
that is not character based that's some
kind of background color or something
like this
but I personally think these character
based ones look okay all right let's
wrap it up for now let's investigate it
a little bit more and and continue I
mean yeah okay okay
see all soon